following this saga has been one of the
more interesting things I've witnessed
watching the anatomy of a scheme like
this it's it's a master class honestly
it's a master class in self victimizing
in tribal izing your audience I mean
honestly
in some ways I get it from the outside
looking in it looks like poor Brian
right poor Brian rose he just wanted to
stream about conspiracy theories and
YouTube didn't allow him to and he's
been victimized
he's been victimized and that's why he's
asking for your money but from another
perspective the whole picture changes I
want to I want to show you this for a
second take a look at Brian roses London
reels socialblade right now this gives
you a much better story of what's
actually going on Ryan Rose has taken
advantage of a gigantic opportunity
turns out yelling censorship is quite
good for your popularity on the platform
you're claiming to be censored by it's a
minute guys it's imminent Brian Rose is
about to be removed from the platform I
mean if I'm really honest with you and
sometimes that's what a leader has to do
is just be straight-up honest is that I
I think it's only a matter of time
before we are removed from that platform
and because he's about to be removed not
only does he need you to watch all his
videos he also need you to support him
we've covered this extensively in a
video series I'm gonna put in a playlist
that I'll link down below you can watch
our full coverage of the London real
situation because it's quite the
elaborate setup but to recap for you
guys real quick he got banned once in a
David Icke life gym he used this to
leverage and $100,000 crowd funding goal
which he then stretched to a million
dollars but he was always copy outing
that he was gonna end his fundraise this
is gonna go on for another ten days
until Rose Icke and we're shutting off
will be gonna be closing down this
fundraising campaign very soon so again
we're closing this thing out on May 3rd
except he didn't and now he's raising
another three million dollars under the
guise of hiring new people now let me
ask you why would you want to pay for
Brian roses staff that's his job as a
business to pay for staff but now he's
just trying to fundraise all of it under
the guise of freedom and I'm being
persecuted meanwhile what have you
actually received well have you received
the technology no because he's using
other platforms to host his material
have you received any equity in this
digital freedom platform no in fact it
gets really interesting when you go to
his Terms of Service and you find out
that oh he could sever this agreement
anytime this is the Terms of Service you
signed when you gave him a million
dollars to play with termination without
prejudice to any other rights long-stem
limited the people receiving the funds
shall have the right to terminate this
agreement at any time by giving the
funders a prior written notice by email
of seven days that's a
get-out-of-jail-free card guys so
anytime he can just study you know what
thanks for the money see ya peace not
only that here's the most hypocritical
part check this out long stem Limited's
other rights remove any content from the
website that it determines is offensive
unlawful threatening defamatory obscene
or otherwise objectionable shall be at
the sole and absolute discretion of long
stem limited we'll wait so hold on let
me get this straight you're telling me
you want to be able to remove content
from your digital freedom platform
because you might see it as a you know
offensive you might see it as maybe
dangerous or obscene or otherwise
objectionable in other words you have a
Community Guidelines which if broken you
reserve the right to remove that content
is that is that basically what you're
saying on your digital freedom platform
right what this is the digital freedom
platform your one million dollars are
going to a platform that can at their
discretion remove any content from the
website that it determines is offensive
and lawful threatening defamatory
obscene or otherwise objectionable aka
YouTube's guidelines you're just it's
unbelievable but I'm happy to say this
there is a silver lining among all of
this which is the people are waking up
and this doesn't mean that they're all
of a sudden happy with what YouTube's
doing but they're realizing what Brian
Rose is doing this isn't its recent
community post you've been milked for a
million surprise surprise he raised it
to a million who thinks he will raise it
to 1.5 million when the current target
is met
it's hilarious there are charities out
there people are starving and all these
idiots throwing money at a company for
no shares to build another
private platform that will have the
exact same issues as the others control
and funding except rather than an open
platform it will be closed to just Brian
and rather than having advertisers pay
for it
you'll have to subscribe you're paying
for something worse under the promise
that it will be better I mean that kind
of summarizes it all doesn't it it is a
closed platform and it is suffering out
of the same issues like I said he's
reserving the right to delete whatever
content he wants on the London real
platform which is just what YouTube does
but I think people are starting to wake
up to what's going on and here's here's
another comment that I like if Brian had
invested in teeka's five coins to five
million and his last five coins he
wouldn't be needing to ask for his money
from his viewers I wonder why he didn't
follow teeka's advice and funny enough
you can't find those videos online
anymore that I criticized him for that
many people criticize them for for
selling out he deleted them he deleted
them after selling that product to use
so look at the game look at what's
happening here first he shills you a
product and then he deletes the evidence
of him ever shilling that product you
can't find it anymore the only evidence
that this sales pitch ever happened was
my video and all the victims that bought
teeka's product and thereby paid Brian
Rose indirectly through affiliate links
and maybe you're thinking well maybe
Brian Rose feels really bad about
selling these ridiculous opportunities
to people that's a nice thought but I
just got something new in my inbox and
urgent alert from Brian Rose hi this is
for your eyes only this millionaire from
New York is inviting you to a special
online event Wednesday May 27th a
hundred percent free it's actually a
giant sales pitch he says if you show up
your mornings might never be the same
again
guess who it is my name is Tim Sykes and
I teach people to trade stocks penny
stocks are speculative companies trading
under five dollars a share hey this is
Tim Seitz millionaire mentor and trader
I am here with my brand new Ferrari and
I wanted to give you a very important
lesson can you hear the clicking sound
can you see these lights blinking
there's something wrong with my Ferrari
I just got this brand new today and
there's something wrong with it
so the lesson here is do Ferrari stock
know do they have problems yes if you
make money and you get enough to have a
Ferrari like this and you have hundreds
of thousands of dollars of just
disposable income that's not gonna solve
all your problems in the world but
[Music]
[Music]
but never shoulda trust
Oh
[Music]